[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
يعتذرون اليكم اذا رجعتم اليهم
قل لا تعتذروا لن نؤمن لكم قد نبانا الله
من اخباركم
وسيرى الله عملكم ورسوله ثم تردون الى
عالم الغيب والشهاده
فينبئكم
بما كن انتم تعملون
سيحلفون بالله لكم اذا انقلبتم اليهم
لتعرضوا عنهم
فاعرضوا عنهم انهم رجس
وماواهم جهنم جزاء
بما كانوا يكسبون
يحلفون
لترضوا عنهم
فان ترضوا عنهم فان الله لا يرضى عن القوم
الفاسقين
الاعراب اشد كفرا ونفاقا
واجدر الا يعلموا حدود ما انزل الله على
رسوله
والله عليم
حكيم
ومن الاعراب من يتخذ ما ينفق مغرما ويتربص
بكم الدوائر
عليهم دائره
السوء
والله سميع عليم
ومن الاعراب من يؤمن يؤمن بالله واليوم
الاخر
ويتخذ ما ينفق
قربات عند الله وصلوات الرسول
الا انها
قربه لهم
سيدخلهم الله في رحمته ان
الله غفور رحيم
والسابقون
الاولون من المهاجرين
والانصار
والذين اتبعوهم
باحسان
رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه
واعد لهم جنات
تجري تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها ابدا
ذلك الفوز العظيم
وممن حولكم من الاعراب منافقون ومن اهل
المدينه
مردوا على النفاق لا تعلمهم نحن نعلمهم
سنعذبهم
مرتين ثم يرد يردون الى ثم يردون الى عذاب
عظيم
واخرون اعترفوا بذنوبهم خلطوا عملا صالحا
واخر سيئا
عسى الله ان يتوب عليهم
ان الله غفور رحيم
خذ من اموالهم صدقه تطهرهم وتزكيهم
بها وصل عليهم
ان صلاتك سكن لهم والله سميع عليم
الم يعلموا ان الله هو يقبل التوبه عن
عباده وياخذ الصدقات
وان الله هو التواب الرحيم
وقل اعملوا فسيرى الله عملكم ورسوله
والمؤمنون
وستردون
الى عالم الغيب والشهاده
فينبئكم
بما كنتم تعملون
واخرون مرجعون لامر الله
اما يعذبهم
واما يتوب عليهم
والله عليم حكيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم رحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
[Arabic recitation]
والذين اتخذوا مسجدا ضرارا وكفرا و
وتفريقا
بين المؤمنين وارصادا لمن حارب الله
وارصادا لمن حارب الله ورسوله من قبل
وليحلفن
ان اردنا الا الحسنى
والله يشهد انهم لكاذبون
لا تقم فيه ابدا
لمسجد اسس على التقوى من اول يوم احق ان
تقوم فيه
رجال يحبون ان يطهر فيه رجال يحبون ان
يطهروا
فيه رجال يحبون ان يتطهروا والله يحب
المطهرين
افمن اسس بنيانه على تقوى
من الله ورضوان خير
امن اسس بنيانه على شفا جرف هار فانهار به
في نار جهنم
والله لا يهدي القوم الظالمين
لا يزال بنيانهم
الذي بنوا ريبه في قلوبهم
الذي بنوا ريبه في قلوبهم الا ان تقطع
قلوبهم
والله عليم حكيم
الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليه وغير المغاوم عليه
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
السلام
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه رحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
আই হউ আপডেট এন আই হুড নিউজ টু শেয়ার ইউ
ফারস্ট
আফটার জুমা
any
pleas you donateable
and sister
pleas
السلام عليكم
جز
so
first anybody
schit
academy there a box there and you can
also ack you give that to my
அஜப now
and ம
and
you be to me
as
ouration and what need
our sch that have
‏reached ma capacity
so the sch enrement is around 90 stud
and we started with something much
smaller we was 50 60 but we add
four more classrooms as you know 2 years
agோ or year half ag we add classro today
we find again aவ
constrain sitation
আলহামদুলিল্লাহ
প্রপার
ইনশল্লাহ
পন্ডিং
একমা
மலஜ
[Silence]
மலம்
‏time
can
any other cann beaged
to be managed properly by the oigation
you got to make sure that you are
managing it properly and expanding it
and using it for the purpose was
intended so
‏be a
for the benit of academy
তা so i also told you right just hope
that you you know if you he it i want
say again that we have a of land that is
a part of this trust right now so our go
now is to colct funds to my and prare
‏to build a building on it for the benit
of the school and school only now
next frid be doing the funding for that
purpose so again I want you to think
between now and then what can you do to
put my into this
that will have a everlasting impact
in terms of hasanat
‏bey
property
build up and use this forever
for the purpose of musl and in this
case it is the benit of the school
is any question anybody has in their
mind that you want to ask now or ask
‏pleas
and how
this
comm fur
so
we you to at bu into understand it
understand the benit of it and you have
any question we clear that between now
and the
স
পইশ
হিস্
‏question pleas
and give me
the here st me ask
the second i just to say is
we we have this oigation that says we
are going to continue feeding the rah
academy we that's the expenses of the
rah academy and that is and
just to add to that been about
the Arizona state
tax
again I want to appeal to you brother
and sister I know that with this
community
most of us lot of us have the tackets
where
state
‏stona
want
to build the musl sch or you
from the sch so if youed that fund that
is again your ta liability so if it is
only 500 ta liability you can direct
that 500 ‏for the sake of academy if you
have 2000 is 300 so pardon
3000 see my numbers are from the p so
those num are signicant so you are up to
you know some of us are paying signicant
money 000 the state taxes because
you there no way to avoid them right so
if you have more ber that 3000
‏takeademy
so was
and at least 14% 13 to 14%
is funded by this prram and this prram
doesn't cost you anything technically
‏anyad
so again
to season here let make one of us if you
have 500 liability you can direct that
so in some cases you may need some
guidance
اوكي ان شاء الله
صلاه
جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
ماشي
استووا واعتدلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
‏If one of our volunteers the security
could
the door and tell everyone to down a
little
we having any convations, please take it
out
your make
الله
اكبرك
وتمرك اسمك وتعج
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم رحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
ان الله اشترى من المؤمنين انفسهم
واموالهم
بان لهم الجنه
يقاتلون في سبيل ل فيقتلون
ويقتلون
وعدا عليه حقا في التوراه والانجيل
والقران
ومن اوفى بعهده من الله
فاستبشروا ببيعكم الذي بايعتم
به وذلك هو الفوز العظيم
التائبون
العابدون الحامدون السائحون
السائحون
الراكعون الساجدون
الامرون بالمعروف والناهون
عن المنكر
والحافظون
لحدود الله
وبشر المؤمنين
ما كان للنبي
والذين امنوا ان يستغفروا للمشركين
ولو كانوا اولي قربى من بعد ما تبين لهم
انهم اصحاب الجحيم
وما كان استغفار
ابراهيم لابيه الا عن موعده
وعدها اياه
فلما تبين له انه عدو لله تبرا منه
ان ابراهيم لاواه حليم
وما كان الله ليضل قوما من بعد اذ هداهم
حتى يبين لهم ما يتقون
ان الله بكل شيء عليم
ان الله له ملك السماوات والارض
يحيي ويميت
وما لكم من دون الله من ولي ولا نصير
لقد تاب الله على النبي والمهاجرين
والانصار
الذين اتبعوه في ساعه العسره من بعد ما
كاد يزيغ قلوب فريق منهم
ثم تاب عليهم انه بهم رؤوف رحيم
وعلى الثلاثه الذين خلفوا
حتى اذا ضاقت عليهم الارض بما رحبت وضاقت
عليهم انفسهم
وظنوا
ان ملجا من الله الا اليه
ثم تاب عليهم ليتوبوا
ان الله هو التواب
الرحيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وكونوا مع
الصادقين
ما كان لاهل المدينه ومن حولهم من الاعراب
ان يتخلفوا عن رسول الله
ان يتخل خلفوا عن رسول الله ولا يرغبوا
بانفسهم
عن نفسه
بانهم لا يصيبهم ظما ولا نصب ولا مخمصه
ولا مخمصه
في سبيل الله
ولا يطون موطئا يغيظ الكفار
ولا ينالون من عدو نيلا الا كتب لهم
الا كتب لهم به عمل صالح
ان الله لا يضيع اجر المحسنين
ولا ينفقون
نفقه صغيره
ولا كبيره
ولا يقطعون واديا الا كتب لهم ليجزيهم
الله احسن ما كانوا يعملون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
السلام
[Silence]
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم
الشيخ
استقيم واعتدلوا
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وما كان المؤمنون لينفروا كافه
فلولا نفر من كل فرقه منهم طائفه
ليتفقهوا في الدين
ليتفقهوا في الدين ولينذروا
قومهم اذا رجعوا اليهم
ولينذروا قومهم اذا رجعوا اليهم لعلهم هم
يحذرون
يا ايها الذين امنوا قاتلوا الذين يلونكم
من الكفار وليجدوا فيكم غلظه
واعلموا ان الله مع المتقين
واذا ما انزلت سوره فمن
يقول ايكم زادته هذه ايمانا
فاما الذين امنوا فزادتهم ايمانا
وهم يستبشرون
واما الذين في قلوبهم
مرض فزادتهم رجسا الى رجسهم
وماتوا وهم كافرون
اولا يرون
انهم يفتنون في كل عام مره او مرتين
ثم لا يتوبون ولا هم يذكرون
واذا ما انزلت سوره نظر بعضهم الى بعض هل
يراكم
هل يراكم من احد ثم انصرف صرفوه
صرف الله قلوبهم
بانهم
قوم لا يفقهون
لقد جاءكم
رسول من انفسكم
عزيز عليه ما عندتم حريص عليكم
حريص عليكم بالمؤمنين
رؤوف رحيم
فان تولوا فقل حسبي الله
فقل حسبي الله لا اله الا هو فان تولوا
فقل حسبي الله لا اله الا هو عليه توكلت
عليه توكلت وهو رب العرش العظيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
ر
تلك ايات الكتاب الحكيم
اكان للناس عجبا ان اوحينا الى رجل رجل
منهم ان انذر الناس
ان انذر الناس وبشر الذين امنوا ان لهم
قدم صدق عند ربهم
قال الكافرون ان هذا لساحر مبين
ان ربكم الله الذي خلق السماوات والارض في
سته ايام
في سته ايام ثم استوى على العرش
يدبر الامر ما من شفيع الا من بعد اذنه
ذلكم الله ربكم فاعبدوه
افلا تذكرون
اليه مرجعكم جميعا وعد الله حقا
انه يبدا الخلق ثم
يعيده
ليجزي الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات بالقسط
والذين كفروا لهم شراب من حميم
وعذاب اليم
بما كانوا يكفرون
هو الذي جعل الشمس ضياء
والقمر نورا
والقمر نورا وقدره منازل لتعلموا عدد
السنين والحساب
ما خلق الله ذلك الا بالحق
يفصل الايات لقوم يعلمون
ان في اختلاف الليل والنهار وما خلق الله
في السماوات والارض لايات
لايات لقوم يتقون
ان الذين لا يرجون لقاءنا ورضوا بالحياه
الدنيا ورضوا بالحياه الدنيا وطمنوا
بها والذين هم عن اياتنا غافلون
اولئك ماواهم
النار بما كانوا يكسبون
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات يهديهم
ربهم يهديهم ربهم بايمان
هم تجري من تحتهم الانهار في جنات
النعيم
دعواهم فيها سبحانك اللهم
وتحيتهم
فيها سلام
واخر دعواهم ان الحمد لله رب العالمين
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولو يعجل الله للناس الشر استعجالهم
بالخير لقضي اليهم اجلهم
فنذروا الذين لا يرجون لقاءنا
في طغيانهم يعمهون
واذا س الانسان ضر دعانا
دعانا لجنبه
او قاعدا او قائما
فلما
كشفنا عنه ضره مر كان لم يدعنا الى ضر مسه
كذلك زين للمسرفين ما كانوا يعملون
ولقد اهلكنا رون من قبلكم لما
ظلموا
لما ظلموا وجاءتهم
رسلهم بالبينات
وما كانوا ليؤمنوا كذلك نجزي القوم
المجرمين
ثم جعلناكم خلائف
في الارض من بعدهم
لننظر
كيف تعملون
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات
قال الذين لا يرجون لقاءنا
قال الذين لا يرجون لقاءت
بقران
ائت بقران غير هذا او بدله قل ما يكون لي
ان ابدله من تلقاء
نفسي ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي
اني اخاف ان عصيت ربي عذاب يوم عظيم قل لو
شاء الله ما تلوته عليكم ولا ادراكم به
فقد لبثت فيكم عمرا من قبله افلا تعقلون
فمن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا او كذب
باياته
انه
لا يفلح المجرمون
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا يضرهم ولا
ينفعهم
ويقولون هؤلاء
شفعاؤنا
عند الله
قل اتنبئون الله بما لا يعلم في السماوات
ولا في الارض سبحانه وتعالى عما يشركون
وما كان الناس الا امه
واحده
فاختلفوه
ولولا كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي بينهم
لقضي بينهم فيما فيه يختلفون
ويقولون لولا انزل عليه ايه من ربه قل
انما
الغيب لله
قل انما الغيب لله فانتظروا
اني معكم
من المنتظرين
واذا اذقنا واذا اذقنا الناس رحمه من بعد
ضراء
فرحوا بها
واذا ذقنا
الناس رحمه من بعد ضراء مستهم اذا لهم مكر
في اياتنا
قل الله اسرع مكرا ان رسلنا ان رسلنا
يكتبون ما تكرون
هو الذي يسيركم في البر والبحر حتى اذا
كنتم في الفلك حتى اذا كنتم في الفلك
وجرين بهم بريح
طيبه وفرحوا بها
وفرحوا بها جاءتها ريح عاصف جاءتها
ريح عاصف وجاءهم
الموجي
بهم دعوا الله مخلصين له الدين
دعوا الله مخلصين له الدين لئن انجيتنا
من هذه لنكونن
من الشاكرين
فلما
انجاهم اذا هم يبغون في الارض بغير الحق
يا ايها
الناس
يا ايها الناس انما بغيكم على انفسكم
انما بغيكم على انفسكم
متاع الحياه الدنيا
انما
بغيكم على انفسكم
متاع الحياه الدنيا
ثم
الينا مرجعكم
فننبئكم
بما كنتم تعملون
انما
مثل الحياه الدنيا كما ان انزلناه
كما
ان انزلناه
من السماء
فاختلط به نبات الارض فاختلط به نبات
الارض مما ياكل الناس والانعام
حتى اذا اخذت الارض زخرفها وازينت
وازينت وظن اهلها انهم قادرون عليها
اتاها امرنا ليلا او نهارا فجعلناها
حصيدا
فج جعلها حصيدا كان لم تغنى بالامس كذلك
نفصل الايات لقوم يعلمون
كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم يتفكرون
والله يدعو الى دار السلام
ويهدي من يشاء
الى صراط
مستقيم
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
يونسك
يونس
حلوه
[Silence]
انا
بسم
[Silence]
كده
‏B
[Silence]
استووا اعتدلوا استووا
استووا
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
والله يدعو الى
السلام ويهدي من يشاء الى صراط مستقيم
للذين احسنوا الحسنى وزياده ولا يرهق
وجوههم قتر ولا ذله اولئك اصحاب الجنه هم
فيها خالدون
والذين كسبوا السيئات جزاء سيئه بمثلها
وترهقهم ذله
ما لهم من الله من عاصم كانما اغشيت
وجوههم قطعا من الليل مظلما
اولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها خالدون
ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذين اشركوا
مكانكم انتم وشركاؤكم
فزينا بينهم وقال شركاؤهم
ما كنتم ايانا تعبدون
فكفى بالله شهيدا بيننا وبينكم ان كنا عن
عبادتكم لغافلين
هنالك تبلو كل نفس ما اسلفت
وردوا الى الله مولاهم الحق وضل عنهم ما
كانوا يف يفترون
قل من يرزقكم من السماء
والارض امن يملك السمع والابصار ومن يخرج
الحي من الميت ويخرج الميت من الحي ومن
يدبر الامر فسيقولون الله
فقل افلا تتقون
فذلكم الله ربكم الحق حق فماذا بعد الحق
الا الضلال
فانا تصرفون
كذلك حقت كلمه ربك على الذين فسقوا انهم
لا يؤمنون
قل هل من شركائكم
من يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده قل الله يبدا
الخلق ثم يعيده فانا تؤفكون
قل هل من شركائكم
من يهدي الى الحق قل الله يهدي للحق
افمن يهدي الى الحق احق ان يتبع امن لا
يهدي الا ان يهدى فما لكم كيف تحكمون
وما يتبع اكثرهم الا ظنا ان الظن لا يغني
من الحق شيئا ان الله عليم بما يفعلون
وما كان هذا القران ان يفترى من دون الله
ولكن تصديق الذي بين يديه وتفصيل الكتاب
لا ريب فيه من رب العالمين
ام يقولون افتراه
قل فاتوا بسوره
من مثله وادعوا من استطعتم من دون الله ان
كنتم صادقين
بل كذبوا بما لم يحيطوا بعلمه ولما ياتهم
تاويله كذلك كذب الذين من قبلهم فانظر كيف
كان عاقبه الظالمين
ومنهم من يؤمن به ومنهم
من لا يؤمن به وربك اعلم بالمفسدين
وان كذبوك فقل لي عملي ولكم عملكم
انتم بريء
مما اعمل وانا بريء مما تعملون
ومنهم من يستمعون اليك افانت تسمع الصم
ولو كانوا لا يعقلون
ومنهم من ينظر اليك
افانت تهدي العمي ولو كانوا لا يبصرون
ان الله لا يظلم الناس شيئا ولكن الناس
انفسهم يظلمون
ويوم يحشرهم ك ويوم يحشرهم كان لم يلبثوا
الا ساعه من النهار يتعارفون بينهم قد خسر
الذين كذبوا بلقاء الله وما كانوا مهتدين
واما نرينك بعض الذين نعدهم او نتوفينك
فالينا مرجعهم
ثم الله شهيد على ما يفعلون
ولكل امه رسول فاذا اذا جاء رسولهم قضي
بينهم بالقسط وهم لا يظلمون
ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم صادقين
قل لا املك لنفسي ضرا ولا نفعا الا ما شاء
الله
لكل امه اجل اذا جاء اجلهم فلا يست
يستاخرون ساعه ولا يستقدمون
قل ارايتم ان اتاكم عذابه بياتا او نهارا
ماذا يستعجل منه المجرمون
اثم اذا ما وقع امنتم
به
الان وقد كنتم به تستعجلون
ثم قيل للذين ظلموا ذوقوا عذاب الخلد هل
تجزون الا بما كنتم تكسبون
ويستنبئونك
احق هو قل اي وربي انه لحق وما انتم
بمعجزين
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ويستنبئونك
احق هو قل اي وربي انه لحق وما انتم
بمعجزين
ولو ان لكل نفس ظلمت ما في الارض لافتدت
به واسروا الندامه لما راوا العذاب
وقضي بينهم بالقسط وهم لا يظلمون
الا ان لله ما في السماوات والارض الا ان
وعد الله حق ولكن اكثرهم لا يعلمون
هو يحيي ويميت واليه ترجعون
يا ايها الناس قد جاءتكم
موعظه من ربكم وشفاء
لما في الصدور وهدى ورحمه للمؤمنين
قل بفضل الله وبرحمته فبذلك فليفرحوا
هو خير مما يجمعون
قل ارايتم ما انزل الله لكم من رزق فجعلتم
منه حراما وحلا
قل ا
الله اذن لكم ام على الله تفترون
وما ظن الذين يفترون على الله الكذب يوم
القيامه
ان الله لذو فضل على الناس ولكن اكثرهم لا
يشكرون
وما تكون في شان وما تتلوا منه من قران
ولا تعملون من عمل الا كنا عليكم شهودا اذ
تفيضون فيه
وما يعزب عن ربك من مثقال ذره في الارض
ولا في السماء
ولا اصغر من ذلك ولا اكبر الا في كتاب
مبين
الا ان اولياء
الله لا خوف عليهم ولا هم يحزنون
الذين امنوا وكانوا يتقون
لهم البشرى في الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره
لا تبديل لكلمات الله
ذلك هو الفوز العظيم
ولا يحزنك قولهم
ان العزه لله جميعا هو السميع العليم
الا ان لله من في السماوات ومن في الارض
وما يتبع الذين يدعون من دون الله شركاء
ان يتبعون الا الظن وان هم الا يخرصون
هو الذي جعل لكم الليل لتسكنوا فيه
والنهار مبصرا
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يسمعون
قالوا اتخذ الله ولدا
سبحانه هو الغني
له ما في السماوات وما في الارض انكم
من سلطان بهذا اتقولون على الله ما لا
تعلمون
قل ان الذين يفترون على الله الكذب لا
يفلحون
متاع في الدنيا ثم الينا مرجعهم ثم نذيقهم
العذاب الشديد بما كانوا يكفرون
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واتل عليهم نبا نوح اذ قال لقومه يا قوم
ان كان كبر عليكم مقامي وتذكيري بايات
الله فعلى الله توكلت
فاجمعوا امركم وشركاءكم
ثم لا يكن امركم عليكم غمه ثم اقضوا الي
ولا تنظرون
فان توليتم فما سالتكم من اجر ان اجري الا
على الله
وامرت ان اكون من المسلمين
فكذبوه فنجيناه ومن معه في الفلك وجعلناهم
خلائف
واغرقنا الذين كذبوا باياتنا
فانظر كيف كان عاقبه المنذرين
ثم بعثنا من بعده رسلا الى قومهم فجاؤوهم
بالبينات
فجاؤوهم
بالبينات فما كانوا ليؤمنوا بما كذبوا به
من قبل كذلك نطبع على قلوب المعتدين
ثم بعثنا من بعدهم موسى وهارون الى فرعون
وملائه باياتنا
فاستكبروا وكانوا قوما مجرمين فلما جاءهم
الحق من عندنا قالوا ان هذا لسحر مبين
قال موسى اتقولون للحق لما جاءكم
اسحر هذا ولا يفلح الساحرون
قالوا اجئتنا لتلفتنا عما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا
وتكون لكما الكبرياء
في الارض وما نحن لكما بمؤمنين
وقال فرعون ائتوني بكل ساحر عليم فلما جاء
السحره قال لهم موسى القوا ما انتم ملقون
فلما القوا قال موسى ما جئتم به السحر ان
الله سيبطله
ان الله لا يصلح عمل المفسدين ويحق الله
الحق بكلماته ولو كره المجرمون
فما امن لموسى الا ذريه من قومه على خوف
من فرعون وملائهم ان يفتنهم
وان فرعون لعالم في الارض وانه لمن
المفسدين
المسرفين
وقال موسى يا قوم ان كنتم امنتم بالله
فعليه توكلوا ان كنتم مسلمين
قالوا على الله توكلنا
ربنا لا تجعلنا فتنه للقوم الظالمين ونجنا
برحمتك من القوم الكافرين
واوحينا الى موسى واخيه فيه ان تبوا
لقومكما بمصر بيوتا واجعلوا بيوتكم قبله
واقيموا الصلاه
وبشر المؤمنين
وقال موسى ربنا انك اتيت فرعون وملاه زينه
واموالا في الحياه الدنيا ربنا ليضلوا عن
سبيلك
ربنا اطمس على اموالهم واسجدد على قلوبهم
فلا يؤمنوا حتى يروا العذاب الاليم
قال قد اجيبت دعوتكما
فاستقيما ولا تتبعان
سبيل الذين لا يعلمون
وجاوزنا ببني اسرائيل
البحر فاتبعهم فرعون وجنوده بغيا وعدوا
حتى اذا ادركه الغرق قال امنت انه لا اله
الا الذي امنت به بنو اسرائيل
وانا من المسلمين
الان وقد عصيت قبل وكنت من المفسدين
فاليوم ننك ببدنك لتكون لمن خلفك ايه ان
كثيرا من الناس عن اياتنا لغافلون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد بوانا بني اسرائيل
مبوا صدق ورزقناهم
من الطيبات
فما اختلفوا حتى جاءهم
العلم ان ربك يقضي بينهم يوم القيامه فيما
كانوا فيه يختلفون
فان كنت في شك مما انزلنا اليك فاسال
الذين يقراون الكتاب من قبلك لقد جاءك
الحق من ربك فلا تكونن من الممترين
ولا تكونن من الذين كذبوا بايات الله
فتكون من الخاسرين
ان الذين حقت عليهم كلمه ربك لا يؤمنون
ولو جاءتهم
كل ايه حتى يروا العذاب الاليم
فلولا كانت قريه امنت فنفعها ايمانها الا
قوم يونس لما امنوا كشفنا عنهم عذاب الخزي
في الحياه الدنيا
كشفنا عنهم عذاب الخزي في الحياه الدنيا
ومتعناهم الى حين
ولو شاء ربك لامن في الارض كلهم جميعا
افانت تكره الناس حتى يكونوا مؤمنين
وما كان لنفس ان تؤمن الا باذن الله
ويجعل الرجس على الذين لا يعقلون
قل انظروا ماذا في السماوات والارض وما
تغني الايات والنذر عن قوم لا يؤمنون
فهل ينتظرون الا مثل ايام الذين خلوا من
قبلهم قل فانتظروا اني معكم من المنتظرين
ثم ننجي رسلنا والذين امنوا كذلك حقا
علينا ننجي المؤمنين
قل يا ايها الناس ان كنتم في شك من ديني
فلا اعبد الذين تعبدون من دون الله
ولكن اعبد الله الذي يتوفاكم
وامرت ان اكون من المؤمنين
وان اقم وجهك للدين حنيفا ولا تك تكونن من
المشركين
ولا تدع من دون الله ما لا ينفعك ولا يضرك
فان فعلت فانك اذا من الظالمين
وان يمسسك الله بضر فلا كاشف له الا هو
وان يردك وان يردك بخير فلا
لفضله
يصيب به من يشاء
من عباده وهو الغفور الرحيم
قل يا ايها الناس قد جاءكم الحق من ربكم
فمن اهتدى فانما يهتدي لنفسه ومن ضل فانما
يضل عليها
وما انا عليكم بوكيل
واتبع ما يوحى اليك واصبر حتى يحكم الله
وهو خير الحاكمين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
كتاب احكمت اياته ثم فصلت من لد حكيم خبير
الا تعبدوا الا الله
انني لكم منه نذير وبشير وان استغفروا
ربكم ثم توبوا اليه يمتعكم متاعا حسنا الى
اجل مسمى ويؤت ذي فضل فضله
وان تولوا فاني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم كبير
الى الله مرجعكم وهو على كل شيء قدير
الا انهم يثنون صدورهم ليستخفوا منه الا
حين يستغشون ثيابهم يعلم ما يسرون وما
يعلنون
انه عليم بذات الصدور
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه اللهم
[Silence]
في
شاء الله
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
والشمس وضحاها والقمر اذا تلاها والنهار
اذا جلاها والليل اذا يغشاها
والسماء
وما بناها والارض وما طحاها ونفس
وما سواها
فالهمها فجورها وتقواها
قد افلح من زكاها
قد افلح من زك كاها وقد خاب من دساها
كذبت ثمود بطغواها
اذ
بعث اشقاها
فقال لهم رسول الله ناقه الله وسقياها
فكذبوه فعقروها
فدمدم عليهم ربهم بذنب
بهم فسواها
ولا يخاف عقباها
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
لايلاف قريش ايلافهم رحله الشتاء
والصيف
فليعبدوا رب هذا البيت
الذي اطعمهم
من جوع وامنهم
من خوف
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا
فيه كما تحب وترضاه
اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد عظم حلمك
فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك
الحمد اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض من عليها
انت خير الوارثين
اللهم ارحم ضعفنا
اللهم ارحم ضعفنا اللهم ارحم ضعفنا واجبر
كسرنا وثبت حجتنا
وسدد السنتنا
واهد قلوبنا
واجب دعوتنا
واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا
يا ربنا سبحانك لا نثني لا نحصي ثناء عليك
اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا الجلال والاكرام
يا حي يا قيوم يا بديع السماوات والارض
ويا رحمن الدنيا والاخره ورحيمهما
اللهم تقبل قبل منا صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وقيامنا
وصالح دعائنا يا رب العالمين.
انا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امائك
نواصينا بيدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا
قضاؤك
نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك او
انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل
القران العظيم ربيع صدورنا
ان تجعل القران العظيم ربيع صدورنا
ونور قلوبنا
وجلاء احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا وغمومنا
وسابقنا الى جناتك جنات النعيم اللهم
ارحمنا بالقران
اللهم ارحمنا بالقران وشفعنا بالقران
واجعله لنا نورا وهدى ورحمه يا سميع
الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم كن للمستضعفين من المسلمين في كل
مكان احرسهم بحراستك
وارعهم برعايتك واب عليهم سور حمايتك
ادخلهم في ضمانك
واجعلهم في امانك وادفع عنا وعنهم ودافع
يا قوي يا جبار سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]